hello in these videos we are going to be
talking about some JavaScript lingo
we're not going to do any actual coding
in this we're not going to learn how to
code in JavaScript I'm just going to
introduce you to some basic terms and
concepts so that when you come across
them later you have an idea of what's
going on before we dive into any
concepts or terms we're going to talk a
little bit about the Mozilla developer
Network and documentation the mdn
Mozilla developer network is open source
documentation for JavaScript if you
haven't been there you need to go you
are going to be using it a lot as you
learn JavaScript documentation is
information about a product provided to
its users what that will look like is
what you see on the MDN it is literally
just instructions on how to use a
language or how to use a library what
you need to type and what it can do as
you continue to learn JavaScript jQuery
any other languages or libraries
documentation is your friend the more
quickly you become familiar and
comfortable reading and utilizing
documentation the more quickly you're
going to grow as a developer what I want
you to take away from this video is go
check out ndn if you have it already
don't be overwhelmed I just want you to
know that it's there and I want you to
be comfortable reading documentation
don't be intimidated you got it I then